lorsque ma présence n'est pas
indispensable n'est pas nécessaire à
paris eh bien je préfère passer ce temps
là à la campagne ou au contact de la
nature des animaux
je dis non pas que je me repose mais ça
m'apporte
non seulement un certain équilibre mais
un goût de vivre que l'on perd dans les
grandes cités vous vécu
où vas-tu aux voitures
ap
s'appelle it au pacha remporté 7-1 la
première fois et puis surtout sur les
taies d'oreillers et dans les
appartements 1
allez montre un peu regardé certains
aliments pour chats et autant les trucs
que les canards des lianes de manger ils
ont refusé ils en mangent comment vous
est venue cette passion des canards au
sein de ses très longs c'est pas
réaction c'est parce qu'étant adolescent
j'étais chasseurs et notamment chasseurs
de canards canards sauvages passé la
nuit dans des pondeuses au froid
et puis à la passe et tiré dans le fond
sur tout ce qui bougeait les chiens les
chercher a dit ravi de faire un compte
et je n'est qu'après que je me suis
rendu compte que que ces canards étaient
beaux je n'ai plus du tout eu envie de
les tirer
et dès que l'occasion a été offerte à ce
moment là j'ai voulu en avoir quand vous
gagnez on ne sait pas c'est pas je ne
les ai pas content et je ne confierai
jamais ce que je sais c'est que les
certain nombré
qu'ils m'apportent s'affaisse de niche
vous avez des cas la religion vous
n'avez pas de chien pourquoi mais ça me
manque eux mais je ne peux pas voilà
voilà
il aurait fallu que j'ai dès que j'ai eu
des chats il rétribue gdt petit chiot
mais maintenant c'est pas compatible
d'abord parce qu'il entend de moins bien
et qu'ensuite même s'il n'avait pas eu
de chat je n'aurais pas eu de chien je
mène une vie qui est une vie un petit
peu haché je pars suivant 3 4 mois et un
chat peut ne peut être malheureux au
bout de trois mois n'ont pas de solitude
puisqu'il a tous les jours le quelqu'un
qui vient m'apporter à manger et un
chien ça ne serait pas la même chose
un chien serait malheureux alors je n'ai
pas voulu avoir un plaisir égoïste pour
rendre un ou plusieurs
shyamalan cefasim sur les chats c'est
très malin sa décence et je vous
racontais juste une anecdote puis je
finirai là mais c'est une anecdote qui
je trouve est importante
pendant l'occupation
j'ai fait partie des équipes de secours
qui allaient à lorient bresse saint
nazaire et ses fins dans les villes qui
étaient bombardés pour dégager les
décombres et surtout dégager les blessés
le plus rapidement possible et un matin
j'ai vu un petit chat noir tout noir en
bretagne dans une ambre est exactement
et je vais adopter avec mes camarades de
groupe un moment donné il sait ni 24
heures après il s'est mis à miauler
d'une façon terrible si bien que j'ai eu
un réflexe et j'ai dit à mes camarades
bon ne dégageront plus reculons et
appelons les les équipes du génie
artificiers le ch a évidemment été le
premier à se sortir de l'endroit où nous
étions donc quand les artificiers se
sont arrivés eh bien il ya une bombe qui
n'avait pas explosé
et ils nous ont dit si vous aviez fait
le moindre geste qui est remuée une
pierre la bombe explosé et bien c'est un
chat noir qui nous a sauvés
et qui a eu justement lui vaudra un sens
du danger que nous n'avions pas bien
pourquoi ces animaux c'est parce que
vous le constatez c'est vivant chacun de
leur manière
celui ci avec énormément de tendresse
jamais connu un qui soit aussi aussi
tendre si affectueux
ensuite les canards qui qui se font les
plumes eux qui ont d'ailleurs un plumage
extraordinaire et pigeons qui volettent
autour de de la maison l'été on voit des
poissons tu veux descendre à l'eau du
bain de sang
voilà et ensuite les truites dont on
parlait tout à l'heure
j'avoue que si tout ça n'était pas la
maison serait plus triste est ce qui
fait que ça on a justement c'est 30
millions d'amis avec soin